[Music]
the possibility of life on mars has been
a topic of interest for years now
thanks to its similarities to early
earth to date we have had no proof of
past or present life on the red planet
cumulative evidence suggests that during
the ancient milwaukee and time period
the surface environment of mars had
liquid water
and may have been habitable for
microorganisms but that doesn't
necessarily mean it had any life
right our hunt for evidence of life
began in the 19th century it continues
today
we send up rovers and explorers to study
the planet we focused on finding water
biosignatures in the soil and rocks and
biomarker gases in the atmosphere
and during our research we managed to
uncover several other things we hadn't
even
thought about today we're going to take
a look at the 10 most
mind-blowing discoveries we have made on
mars welcome back to our channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring the bell
so you never miss a video from us number
one an ancient steam bed
just seven weeks after the landing of
nasa's curiosity rover
mission scientists announced that it had
found an ancient steam bed where water
once flowed roughly knee-deep for
thousands of years at a time
the discovery suggests that at least
some parts of mars may have been
habitable billions of years ago
since life here on earth thrives pretty
much anywhere liquid water is found
number two a habitable environment while
there curiosity used its hammering drill
to bore 2.5 inches or 6.4 centimeters
into a red planet outcrop called john
klein note that this is the very first
time
any rover had ever drilled into a rock
to collect samples on another world
it was also the deepest we have ever
been on an alien planet
and it allowed curiosity to study the
martian environment as it existed
billions of years ago
leading to perhaps the rover's biggest
scientific discovery to date
a habitable environment curiosity
spotted some of the key chemical
ingredients required to support life and
the great powder it drilled out of the
john client rock
these included sulfur nitrogen hydrogen
oxygen
phosphorus and carbon the fine grain
rock also contained clay minerals
suggesting an aqueous environment long
ago perhaps a lake that was neutral in
ph
and not too salty another rover called
opportunity also found evidence that
mars could have been habitable for
millions of years
at the rim of the endeavour crater cape
york the rover discovered ferric and
illuminous smektite clays and finely
layered metagenic formation rocks that
precede the endeavor impact event
these are the oldest rocks examined by
opportunity we think roughly four
billion years old
and they were exposed to waters much
more habitable than the waters that led
to the burns formation
number three martian cauliflowers in
nasa's spirit rover stumbled upon an
oddly shaped yet familiar object
poking out of the martian surface in the
gusev crater scientists called the
structure cauliflower
because of its resemblance to the
vegetable images taken by the rover show
a series of mineral deposits made up of
opaline silica
on earth these silica formations are
associated with microbial activity
when the rover snapped images of these
structures on mars some suggested that
these had been formed by martian
bacteria however
it could also be shaped by
non-biological processes like wind
erosion
since mars climate is very different
from earth's number four
dangerous radiation levels curiosity
detected radiation levels that exceed
what nasa allows for their astronauts
the radiation assessment detector or rad
instrument on the curiosity found that
two forms of radiation
pose potential health risks to
astronauts in deep space one is galactic
cosmic rays which are particles caused
by supernova explosions
and other high energy events outside the
solar system the other
is solar energetic particles associated
with solar flares
and coronal mass ejections from the sun
with this information
we can build spacecraft and spacesuits
that are able to protect our astronauts
on deep space missions
number five geological diversity it
seems our planet earth isn't the only
one that's geologically eventful
scientists were surprised by the sheer
variety of soil and rock they found in
the gale crater where curiosity landed
according to nasa their rover found
different types of gravel
steam bed deposits what could possibly
be volcanic rock
water transported sand dunes mudstones
and cracks filled with mineral veins
and all of these yield rich clues about
mars past
number six spikes in methane gas
telescopic observations from earth show
us spikes in methane gas in mars
atmosphere in the years before the
curiosity rover arrived
it seemed to come and go in large plumes
this was quite surprising because
methane is thought to be destroyed
quickly by other chemicals and wasn't
thought to be present
right now mars's atmosphere averages
about 1 part methane per 2 billion parts
of mars air
and a few times over the last 8 years
the rover has detected spikes of 10 to
20 times as much
though detecting methane on mars is
exciting because it resembles something
we actually have on earth too
there could also be non-biological
explanations for it to exist
we just can't seem to theorize what
those reasons are yet the presence of
methane in the red planet's atmosphere
remains a mystery number seven dust
devils
the opportunity rover captured an image
of the landscape in 2016 showing dust
devils much like what we get on earth
the sand in the lower part of a martian
dust devil would be a hazard the
atmospheric pressure on mars is only one
percent of what it is on earth so
astronauts wouldn't feel much wind
against them but they would still be
impacted by high-speed debris
plus the dust and sand could be
electrically charged to the point of
creating electromagnetic interference in
space suits and vehicles
some dust devils captured from orbit
span one to two kilometers across their
base
and they tower eight to ten kilometers
high number eight
oxygen fluctuation of all things nasa
found mind-boggling fluctuations of
oxygen in mars's atmosphere
that don't match up to what we have
known about the planet so far while
researchers expected some change in the
levels of oxygen on the planet they are
struggling to explain what they found a
whopping 30
jump in oxygen was discovered in the
summer forcing nasa to check the
equipment to make sure it was working
properly
they then appeared to return to normal
during the autumn it seemed like
something was producing the oxygen
and then taking it away melissa traynor
a planetary scientist at nasa's goddard
space flight center said quote
this is the first time we're seeing this
interesting behavior over multiple years
we don't totally understand it for me
this is an open call to all the smart
people out there who are interested in
this
see what you can come up with number
nine organic matter that has survived to
this day
curiosity has found that ancient mars
had enough carbon in the rocks and soils
to serve as raw materials for life
if it ever existed it found that the
lake bed rocks in the gale crater had a
diversity of organic molecules
most of them are simple and only a few
carbon atoms in length
yet it's possible that these
carbon-based molecules on mars
may be fragments of more complex organic
molecules that have degraded over
billions of years
and it's surprising that these simple
molecules have even survived for this
long
it's possible that they were long buried
and only recently appeared on the
surface through natural processes of
erosion
but the fact that such molecules were
available makes the ancient environment
even more suitable for life
number 10 water saving the best for last
the reconnaissance orbiter revealed
signatures of hydrated minerals on
slopes where we often see mysterious
streaks
these streaks seem to ebb and flow and
they darken and appear to flow down
steep slopes during warmer seasons
these downhill flows known as recurring
slope linnae are often described as
possibly related to liquid water
many dried up riverbeds deltas lake
basins and inland seas prove
that the red planet was once blue it may
have had
one or several oceans in the northern
hemisphere but all we see of them today
are in the forms of briny underground
lakes and locked away in polar caps
we can estimate how much water as ice
liquid or vapor would have been present
at various points throughout mars's
history
in its earliest years all the water in
liquid form would have covered the
planet in a shallow ocean
150 to 800 feet deep that's nothing
compared to the 11 000 feet on earth but
it's definitely more than what we
expected to find
once every 26 months earth and mars
align it's perfect for traveling the
shortest distance possible reducing the
commute to about six months
our biggest space agencies are taking it
upon themselves to launch probe after
probe
taking advantage of the opportunity the
most recent of them happened in the
summer of 2020.
three countries launched their
spacecraft to mars the united arab
emirates launched their hope spacecraft
china launched their chianwen won and
the united states deployed its
perseverance rover at the end of july
private spaceflight companies like
spacex are already looking at colonizing
mars and making humans a multi-planetary
species
given the overwhelming amount of
evidence we have had that life on mars
could one day be possible
the day isn't far away when we start
listing our planet of birth
on our passports enjoy the video then be
sure to hit the like button and check
out more videos on tech and our future
on the simply tech channel thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time